you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
as russia's president putin joins a
growing list of world leaders not
attending cop26 its president alex
sharma says net zero commitments from
the g20 are critical to stopping global
warming
a warning from the un that the world's
biggest fossil fuel producing countries
must cut emissions by more than half to
keep global temperatures below dangerous
levels
and as london's mayor becomes chair of a
global group of cities focused on
fighting climate change sadiq khan tells
us his plans to help the capital reach
net zero emissions by 2030.
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes that are happening to our world
right now and we challenge those who are
coming up with the solutions
now the russian president vladimir putin
has decided not to attend the global
climate summit in glasgow now just 11
days away well he joins a list of world
leaders who are not going to cop 26
raising some doubt that a global
agreement can be reached to ensure that
the earth's temperature does not rise to
dangerous levels but the events
president alok sharma said he was still
confident that more
more countries would commit to national
action plans on climate change in the
coming days
i mean russia will send obviously a a
delegation uh and you know we want you
know all world leaders to to to come
obviously but you know what will also be
critical is what happens during those
two weeks and how the individual
delegations uh interact you know just uh
in the last few days announced a net
zero commitment uh which i think is a
move forward uh but you know obviously
in the it wouldn't surprise you to to
know that in the conversations that i've
been having i have raised the issue of
the ndc and that's the case for for for
every country but the the g20 really
matter here chair because they represent
80 percent of global emissions um if all
of them were on a pathway uh to 1.5 uh
or net zero by by uh 2050 we would be
looking at limiting global warming to
1.7 degrees that's just the actions of
the g20 and that's why what they do
matter so much
well our climate change correspondent
hannah thomas peter joins us now uh
hannah sharma keeping his cool there but
if the big hitters don't come does the
conference lose momentum
of course it does you know i think there
is an issue here for uh
for alok sharma and his team
it really does matter who turns up in
person
if only for the optics the delegations
of china because we know that
president
xi jinping might not is unlikely to come
in person we know that china is going to
send a delegation we don't know for sure
if they're going to have a mandate to
negotiate on their nation's behalf
and or what their their their situation
will be when they attend glasgow um
that's just the brutal truth of it and
you know russia is less important than
china you know as far as negotiations go
but it still is going to sting that
putin isn't turning up in person
but i do think that we've heard an awful
lot from the big players like the uk and
the us who have been frantically trying
to manage expectations around attendance
they have tried very hard not to get
into a back and forth about who or his
who or who is not going to be attending
and they are constantly saying that
they're not going to you know attach the
success of cop to physical attendance
but their actions probably speak louder
than words betray the reality of how
they are thinking about the importance
of attendance because the us has made a
great thing about how it is sending some
13 high-level representatives from the
u.s government the uk of course is going
to do the same
as host they've made a big play of
welcoming
australia's prime minister scott
morrison because he is he has confirmed
that he is attending in person this
stuff really matters and when you
finally get down to that negotiating
room if you talk to negotiators as i
have done a lot in the past couple of
weeks when you have people in the room
who have the mandate to make decisions
on behalf of their nation that is when
quick progress is made on difficult
issues so of course vladimir putin's
saying he's not turning up in person is
going to impact proceedings
okay well not too late to change their
minds is it hannah thank you very much
indeed
now despite a lot of promises to cut
those emissions some of the world's
biggest fossil fuel producing countries
are planning to increase production of
oil coal and gas but the annual un
production gap report says that they
must cut production by more than half
for there to be any chance of keeping
global temperatures below dangerous
levels well let's take a look at some of
those key findings this line here it
shows emissions that are generated from
fossil fuel production that the main
countries expect to produce up to 2040.
well the report analyzes 15 countries it
includes the uk china the us and india
and it finds they are collectively
projecting an increase in global oil and
gas production and only a modest
decrease in coal production over the
next two decades but but many of them
are promising to lower emissions or
achieve net zero which would lower their
carbon emissions from fossil fuel
production and that is shown here by the
green line
however that level of emission is still
more than twice the amount needed to
limit global warming to 1.5 degrees by
2030. that is shown here by this yellow
line
governments need to recognize that they
they must link up internally to
where where where a major commitment is
being made publicly at cop26 so for
example countries that are formally
committing to no longer build coal power
stations
and and pivoting away saying we will
never build a coal power station that
needs to be reflected through to other
parts of government that are making
making decisions about fossil fuel
production so the uk is a great example
we've got a policy called maximizing
economic recovery
mer which is effectively a policy which
has been around for some time now seems
to be very hard to dislodge which uh
which gives the uk um a clear mandate to
pull as much oil and gas out of the
north sea as possible currently that
doesn't align with the uk's quite
progressive net zero targets and and
other climate change policies so what we
need to see is governments acting to
close that gap to uh to make sure that
the climate goals the climate objectives
that they're setting triple all the way
down and are reflected in their fossil
fuel production policies
now some other climate news around today
and a hydroelectric power plant in
brazil is facing an energy crunch that's
amid record low river and rainfall
levels the itaipu dam which supplies
around 10 percent of the energy consumed
in brazil and 86 in paraguay has
recorded its lowest output ever well
severe droughts linked to climate change
are complicating the shift away from
fossil fuels to renewable sources like
hydroelectric
at least 46 people have died and several
are missing after floods triggered by
heavy rain hit the northern indian state
of uttarakhand the state has seen heavy
rain for the past three days flooding
roads destroying bridges and causing
landslides meteorological experts warn
that climate change has not only
increased the frequency of the rains in
the region but also their intensity
and french beekeepers are anticipating
the worst honey harvest in decades
unseasonably cold and wet weather has
prevented bees from producing honey and
the beekeepers association unaf expects
the overall harvest to be down to just a
third of last year's the unaf president
said that irregular weather patterns
linked to climate change will have a
lasting impact on honey production
now the mayor of london sadiq khan is to
become the next chair of the c40 cities
network that's a group of almost 100
major cities all around the world
dedicated to addressing climate change
now he wants london to become a world
leader in tackling air pollution and
climate change and hopes that action
taken in the capital can inspire and
accelerate climate measures in other
cities well i spoke to him a little
while ago and started by asking how
london can become net zero by 2030 that
is his pledge 20 years before the rest
of the uk
what we can't do
is have politicians kicking the can down
the road with targets 20 30 years in the
future when they're not around that's
one of the reasons i'm concerned
about a target of zero carbon by 2050
our government has to reduce emissions
by 68
by then this decade we're nowhere near
against that in london we've shown with
our policies uh the world's first
ultra-low emission zone one example we
now have in london more electric buses
than any city in western europe since i
became mayor we now have more than a
third of the charging points in the
entire country more rapid charging
points than any city in western europe
we've got to take action now not wait uh
for 10 years or 20 or 30 years you
mentioned the ultra low emission zone
coming in on the 25th of october but 80
of london vehicles won't need to pay
this and it doesn't cover all of london
does it so i'm just wondering whether
you think you might have to tighten the
parameters of it to achieve your goals
uh looking to paris for an example which
is banning all diesel cars by 2024.
well hold on a sec the reason why so
many of our vehicles are now complying
is because of our policies in 2017 which
is when i announced when the universe
would be coming in and the world's first
toxicity charge came in only 37
of vehicles were compliant because of
our policies more of our vehicles are
compliant you less compliance so i can
only be criticized uh for taking action
now look i'm not willing to wait to
2025.
we're going to take action now so even
though
uh paris great city great mayor is in in
four years time
saying they're going to ban uh diesel
that does nothing to improve the quality
of air now at the moment in london as we
speak there are still children whose
lungs are stunted permanently because of
the toxic adults with a whole host of
health issues from asthma to cancer
dementia heart disease and more than 4
000 premature deaths every year now 2025
is too far away
london is not central to the
government's leveling up agenda is it if
you don't get the money that you need
will council tax bills need to rise
look you don't get a national recovery
without a london uh recovery you don't
get to zero carbon rather than playing
its uh role in doing so and we want to
do is work with the government we're on
the same side here
the government and those of us in city
hall are united in our efforts to get to
zero carbon united and their efforts to
clean up our area but also united to
have a national uh recovery from city
hall we're investing in huge sums in
retrofit homes we're also working with
the private sector
uh with the green finance institution to
make sure we can leverage in as much
money as from the private sector as we
can in relation to this important area
but the government's gonna play its role
as well but mr khan can you tell
londoners that they will not see big
increases in their council tax bills to
pay for the green ambitions of london
no i i'm not gonna tax raising powers
even if i had the powers to do so uh the
council tax pals we have in uh london is
focused upon uh areas that are really
important to
london what we can't have a situation
where this really important issue to
london is climate change and air
pollution is paid for just by families
and businesses we need the government to
step in uh as well
okay mr city khan thank you very much
for your time thanks stay safe
well do stay with us because coming up
after the break i'm going to be joined
by the lecturer in international
relations jen allen and mohammad ado
director of the think tank power shift
africa we're going to be discussing if
the uk is a role model on net zero and
how cities like london can play a vital
part in tackling climate change
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm skye's
climate change correspondent
the uk is a world leader in wind
[Music]
power it's part of the congo basin
rainforest which is such an important
ecosystem it's known as the lungs of
africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me i might be just very
naive but i do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
i'm confident for the last 30 years we
have known how bad it is i'm not here to
apologize i'm here to fight for the next
step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these this sofas and people's
desks and children's books and you can
see inside this home here people trying
to to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
i think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of this beauty
around us
the future
of you and me
[Music]
did you know if we tried to use less
energy we could help reduce air
pollution
what like turning off the lights and
stuff yeah
the morning will be fine for most after
patchy early rain over southern england
clears but there'll be showers in the
north and west they'll be wintry on
northern hills it will be much colder
than recently with a raw wind in the
north and east bringing coastal gales
the afternoon will bring a few showers
into the midlands but there'll be little
change elsewhere the push of clean cold
air from the northern atlantic means the
air pollution index where one means low
pollution and 10 means very high will be
low
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show here on sky news well we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day we have with
us the lecturer in international
relations at cardiff university jen
allen and muhammad ado director of think
tank powershift africa
now it's been a really big week hasn't
it the uk government has set out its net
zero strategies said to be the most
comprehensive plan of any major
industrialized country and with just
days before the global gaze fixes firmly
on glasgow for cop26 is the strategy a
good example to the world i'm going to
speak to you first mohammed on there so
it took a long time to get this document
didn't it we kept waiting it's a big fat
document outlining the government's plan
is it worth the paper it's written on
i don't think so and i don't think
anyone
really wants to see a far-off net zero
pledge
that will supposedly balance the uk's
emissions budget by mid century
and and by using tools including
unproven you know techno fixes i think
what we want is
what we want to see is actually what the
uk is going to do today tomorrow and
every year to come
to eliminate its major sources of
emissions including its continued fossil
fuel production and use to be able to
address the current climate emergency we
need real plans real solutions real
finance and real zero for an agent just
transition
so clearly you don't think that that's
it
clearly you don't think that's what this
document represents and what about you
jen i mean the uk government likes to
think of itself as a world leader here
in its climate pledge pledges is that
delusional
well you're right it's been a bit a big
week i think about a dozen or more
policies were put out the last day
totaling over 1800 pages so we're all a
bit in digestion mode right now and
trying to figure out what it all means
it's definitely better than where we
were and it's definitely
puts the uk
in good stead when we compare it to
other countries
it's not enough to get us to net zero
and
there's still some policies in there
missing especially around investment
but we do have to admit this is a
serious piece of work that looks across
the government in all of the departments
and looks at what they can do and what
their targets should be
so
it's better than where we were and it's
a good step forward it's just not quite
enough yet
and mohammed the key to all of this
isn't it is credibility because if
government policy is credible then you
get private investment at pouring in and
then you can encourage individuals to
change their behavior and how far away
do you think the government is from
being credible on climate
i think they've included some good stuff
so the strategy of course includes
investment in expanding electric
vehicles something i think we shall
celebrate and and welcome they start on
offshore wind they starve on you know
the creation of green hydrogen you know
all these things are important but what
you know the challenge that we will face
is actually whether we can be able to
even mobilize the funding that is
required to be able to implement this
strategy i think this strategy is still
seriously unfunded it doesn't get us to
zero it doesn't get us to zero within
the time frame that will allow us to
hold global warming to below 1.5
and it needs the support of tertiary if
it's going to be effective i think what
is going to help us is if we if we can
actually mobilize the work government
behind the strategy and be able to
revise the strategy so that it gets us
to real zero
within a time frame that we can actually
hold global warming to below 1.5 and so
without funds uh without funds that will
actually allow this strategy to be
delivered i don't think it will live up
to the hype so the government is
actually in danger of acting and and
promising us grand you know promises
but not delivering and i think if it
does that right i think it will inspire
the rest of the world and we'll see a
race to the top
and jen some of the sectors that
muhammad was mentioning there that are
high points that the government's
focused on are already profitable aren't
they how does the government go about
encouraging money into technologies
which are still quite experimental not
yet profitable
that's the big question so there's a
role for government to play in terms of
providing initial investment there's
also a role for government to play in
terms of
an investment bank or a way to sort of
nurture those technologies until they're
commercially viable
there is a huge piece of this missing
which is how are they going to mobilize
private investment into this
so as muhammad has said it's underfunded
right now we don't know where all this
money is coming from there's sort of an
idea that the private sector is going to
help out
but without a strategy to mobilize that
private finance
we're not sure how we're going to hit
most of these targets or fulfill a lot
of these promises in the net zero plan
yeah and there's trillions out there
sort of so-called savings glut well
let's move the conversation on the uk
wants to be a global leader on net zero
as we've been saying well that is by
2050. london's mayor however sadiq khan
wants his city to be net zero by 2030.
now that is ambitious but with more than
half of the world living in urban areas
cities and the people in them will need
to play a crucial role in the green
transition mohammed i'm interested to
bring you in on this you're talking to
us from nairobi it's a city which has
seen rapid urbanization there's a lot of
work isn't there for your city to
to commit to its green
potential
yeah
i think we in the in the developing
world i think what we've seen is cities
growing rapidly and i think it's
important that they grow but they grow
in a low carbon way and and we need to
do everything to help our cities become
greener rather than ending up to be big
polluting metro policies i think
that will need to be re-engineered you
know later and so i think it's important
for us to get this message through that
the way we've approached cities we need
to change our mindset about them we need
to change the design of our cities i
think people living and working together
can help reduce emissions and so what we
need to do this time is create cities
with a mixture of homes and shops and
workplaces that are close to our
commuting
and shopping trips so that we can have
them shorter and we can actually be able
to get to places by walking by cycling
and having an effective public transport
i think if we we design cities
and and do that in a way that we can
actually help
make the most out of the little space
that we have we've now seen particularly
in nairobi and this is true for a lot of
the developing country cities a lot of
migration to the major cities and so
space is scarce and so what we need is
modern blocks of flux that are efficient
use of space that can also be quite
energy efficient and if we build these
with the right materials with proper
insulation i think we can get our cities
greener and and help them contribute to
the global efforts to tackle climate
change
just want to bring you in here talking
about sadiq khan he thinks he can go net
zero by 2030 is that just a gimmick or
can he do it
it's tall ask but cities are absolutely
crucial they're about 70 of global
emissions and if you think about cities
like london we tend to build on
coastlines and around big rivers
and that's a big problem when we have
sea level rise and flooding so building
resilience in cities is just as
important as net zero and it can't be
overlooked when we're talking about
cities and climate change okay jen allen
mohamed ado really good to have you both
on the program thank you that is
everything from us for today joining us
on the show tomorrow to discuss all of
the big issues will be fatima ibrahim
from green new deal and also bob ward
from grantham research institute hope to
see you tomorrow evening
[Music]
you